welcome back to retro rewind I am so
happy to be back talking about awesome
stuff from the past I have a lot of fun
doing these and I appreciate the fact
that you guys are getting into him too
this week is gonna be something
completely whatever I was just like just
you know screw it I want to talk about
this and we're talking about something
it's a little bit personal to me and
something that I've watched evolve and
grow over time now I have done a retro
rewind for Toonami and that was sort of
about anime from the mid 90s on and how
it really changed the anime scene this
video is going to be about before that
time how anime became known in the u.s.
but not quite popular yet in its early
days it was largely referred to as
japanimation or animation from Japan or
Japan amay that's pretty much died out
nowadays and it's more commonly referred
to as anime but in its early days
japanimation was what I would say to the
comics store owner when I was curious if
he had anything animated from Japan so
let's talk about some of the early
movies that I saw on the comics store
shelf as a kid some of these VHS is
right here in fact many of my memories
with these movies revolve around moments
in which I stared at the covers of the
VHS is going I'm never gonna be allowed
to see that but man does that look cool
so let's start talking about some of
these they were 11 came out in 1986 I
saw this for the first time because the
Hollywood video rental store nearby my
house had it on VHS and I picked it up
and it was one of the first animes that
I wrote a review for on my old website
that I used to run it's no longer on the
Internet I wrote a review for this and I
remember being so enthralled by it
because it had a very interesting plot
ten people are involved in this intense
training experiment in space they're all
trapped on a spaceship and they
basically have to figure out how to
survive and become a team but when they
discover there is an eleventh passenger
that's not supposed to be there that's
when things get really strange it's also
a very early film and an animated one no
less that tackled very mature themes one
of them being not being entirely
comfortable with the gender you were
born being and I rewatched the film
again a couple months ago and I think it
still holds up very well I first heard
the film Lily Kat because of the sci-fi
channel this film was shown on this
by channel back in the day on their
Saturday anime block where they used to
show hardcore cutting edge animation as
they called it Saturday mornings on the
sci-fi channel it's Japanese animation
in the raw and this ain't no swimming
that's pure power and sheer G see ready
to receive this sacrifice Saturday anime
on a sci-fi channel coming this fall
this film is a complete ripoff of the
movie alien aesthetically the crew the
way the crew looks there's a computer on
board they refer to as mother there's
just not like an alien per se there's a
virus that's jumping between people and
a cat that is in some way involved with
it but it most definitely fits into this
vibe of movies because a lot of people
back in the day referred to japanimation
as just anything animated out of Japan
but for me it was always like the more
edgy violent maybe there was a lot of
nudity or blood like those anime films
to me that was always japanimation like
this slightly more adult anime not
hentai which believe me I saw a lot of
that when I was a kid at least not let
me rephrase that
I didn't see a lot of hentai when I was
a kid I saw a lot of hentai VHS tapes at
a comic store and I went those covers
look interesting
can I have never mind I can't have that
can I now obviously one of the biggest
ones was ghost in the show this movie
came out in 1995 and it was sort of like
hey America anime is awesome and it
helped popularize it more film critics
like Roger Ebert and Gene Siskel even
reviewed it on their show and both
recommended it
this film is marvelous it is challenging
its adults the animation and action is
brilliantly handled still to this day
it's visually stunning and the first
time I saw it was actually at home on
DVD in like the early 2000s because when
I first came out I missed it and then I
would always see the VHS cover and
obviously there's a lot of boobs like
right on the cover and my mom is always
like I don't know about that one the mom
it's a cartoon ah I don't know if that's
the type of cartoon you should be
watching but mom it's animated like Lion
King I don't think that's like Lion King
Chris hmm my mom was clever back then
and the newest film I planned on talking
about was
thick blue directed by status icon or
Satoshi Kon or however you want to say
it this is a marvelous animation that
highly influenced Darren Aronofsky who
actually bought the remake rights for
perfect blue just so he could recreate a
scene in requiem for a dream and tons of
people myself included noticed a lot of
similarities between Black Swan and
perfect blue despite the fact that
Aronofsky denies these connections
they're there whether he likes it or not
and very obvious perfect blue is very
Hitchcockian it's very suspenseful and
it is darkly violent I remember seeing
this cover all the time thinking it was
actually a woman who had her hands tied
up and I was like oh my god this is like
some torture stuff what's happening here
is can i watch this one mom no probably
not son I'm not thinking that's a but
it's it's like Toy Story it's animated
no it's that's not like Toy Story Chris
that's a little bit different yeah mom
you're still clever one of the
lesser-known films are one to talk about
in this video was Venus Wars I also
rented this from Hollywood video back in
the day on VHS and I was also inclined
to write a review for this on my old
website which I did so at the library
because of the time I didn't have the
internet so I went to the library and I
wrote reviews for things like Venus Wars
and that's how I spent a lot of my
teenage years doing stuff like that and
movies like this really inspired me back
then it inspired me to look at animation
differently and I watched this just the
other day it looks marvelous on blu-ray
there's such a grit and realism to this
old style of animation I'm going to talk
a little bit more about that at the end
of this video
Ninja Scroll or as I like to call it
blood and boobs and more boobs boobs
boobs boobs this movie came out in 93
and was big in the anime scene in the
early 90s because it was like oh my gosh
this ain't no Speed Racer there's some
going down in this movie and I
never got to see it until I was an adult
this one but I was like I almost sort of
got away with ghost in the shell' but as
soon as my mom turned it around and was
like absolutely not for children 18 plus
I was like oh okay uh I guess I'm not
going to win this battle and of course
the film that some view as the one that
really started it all for America
Akira came out in 1988 or Akira or
whatever you want to say it's really up
to you from what
I understand just just call it whatever
you want this movie is stunning I also
saw it for the first time as an adult
because again it has a lot of mature
themes it's very very violent and I
loved it as an adult but as a kid my
parents were like just go watch your
clamshell VHS of the big green or the
Sandlot just just just stick with that I
mean just the opening motorcycle chase
scene alone in Acura makes it worth
watching today it's still stunning and
I'm still waiting for somebody to come
along and make a great adaptation of an
anime film or an anime TV show if you
watch some of these older films and
compare them to the way anime is
produced today now I'm not talking about
movies like the boy and the Beast or
spirited away or Studio Ghibli's amazing
animations those films have incredible
animation I'm talking about really the
TV shows of today with anime and even
some of the lesser produced anime films
that have a smaller budget the animation
today it's very digital it's very glossy
it's almost fake the animation for some
of these older films in Japan was
wonderful it felt real it felt like you
could reach into that world and actually
touch it and I think we have gone way
too far away from hand-drawn cel
animation and we're now into this
digital glossy computerized world and I
wish that more animation films looked
and sounded more like these films and
yeah some of them are a little
low-budget not the greatest but they
look amazing still to this day and
that's saying something that's really
crazy I mean some of these movies are
getting close to 30 years old and they
still look phenomenal that's got to say
something about that animation style and
I hope more people are drawn to it in
the future
drawn to it I didn't mean for that to
happen guys thank you so much as always
for watching this retro rewind on the
early days of what some anime fans refer
to as the japanimation era look forward
to next week's hilarious 'ti I don't
know what it's going to be it but it's
going to be fun you guys are the best
thank you so much as always for watching
and thank you to the wife of this
amazing shirt that I love if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes